let me return to that question about uh
maybe the conversation you were having
a while ago with Larry Page maybe
looking to the longer future
of uh social robotics of using spot to
connect with human beings perhaps in the
home do you see a future there if we
were just sort of
hypothesize or dream about a future
where a spot like robots are in the home
as pets social robot we definitely think
about it and and we would like to get
there
we think the pathway to getting there is
you know likely through these industrial
applications
and then Mass manufacturing you know
let's figure out what how to melt how to
build the robots how to make the
software so they can really do a broad
set of skills that's going to take
real investment to get there
performance first right the principle of
the company has always been really make
the robots do useful stuff
and so you know the the
social robot companies that tried to
start Someplace Else by just making a
cute interaction mostly they haven't
survived
and so we think the utility
really needs to come first and that
means you have to Heart solve some of
these hard problems and so to get there
we're going to go through the design and
software development in industrial and
then that's eventually going to let you
reach a scale that could then be
addressed to a commercial uh consumer
level Market
and so yeah maybe we'll be able to build
a smaller spot with an arm that could
really go get your beer for you
but there's things we need to figure out
still how to safely really safely if
you're going to be interacting with
children you better be safe and right
now we we count on a little bit of
standoff distance between the robot and
people so that you don't pinch a finger
you know in the robot
so you've got a lot of things you need
to go solve before you jump to that
consumer level product well there's a
kind of trade-off in safety because it
feels like in the home
you can fall
like you're you don't have to be as good
at like you're allowed to fail in
different ways in more ways as long as
it's safe for the humans so it just
feels like an easier problem to solve
because it feels like in the factory
you're not allowed to fail
that may be true
um but I also think the variety of
things a consumer level robot would be
expected to do will also be quite broad
yeah and they're going to want to get
the beer and know the difference between
the beer and a Coca-Cola or my snack
and or you know they're all going to
want you to clean up the dishes
uh you know from the table without
breaking them
those are pretty complex tasks and so
there's there's still work to be done
there so to push back on that here's
what application I think they'll be very
interesting I think the application of
being a pet a friend so like no tasks
yeah just be cute because I not cute not
cute like the dog is more a dog is more
than just cute a dog is a friend is a
companion there's something about just
having interacted with them and maybe
because I'm hanging out alone with the
robot dogs a little too much but like
there's a
there's a connection there and it feels
like that connection is not should not
be disregarded No it should not be
disregarded
robots that can somehow communicate
through their physical gestures or
you're going to be more attached to in
the long run do you remember IBO the
Sony IBO yeah they sold over a hundred
thousand of those maybe 150 000.
you know what probably wasn't considered
a successful product for them they
suspended that eventually and then they
brought it back Sony brought it back and
people definitely you know treated this
as a as a pet as an as a companion
um and I think that will come around
again
um
will you get away without having any
other utility
maybe in a world where we can really
talk to our simple little pet because
you know chat GPT or some other
generative AI has made it possible for
you to really talk and what seems like a
meaningful way maybe that'll open the
social robot
up again
um
that's probably not a path we're going
to go down because again we're so
focused on performance and utility
we can add those other things also but
we really want to start from that
Foundation of utility I think yeah but I
I also want to predict that you're wrong
on that so which is that the very path
you're taking which is creating a great
robot platform will very easily take a
leap to adding uh
a Chad GPT like capability maybe gpt5
and there's just so many open source
Alternatives you could just plop that on
top of spot
and because you have this robust
platform and you're figuring out how to
mass manufacture it and how to drive the
cost down and how to make it you know
reliable all those kinds of things it'll
be a natural transition to where just
adding tragic routine I do think that
being able to verbally Converse or even
Converse through through gestures you
know part of part of these learning
models is that you know you can now Look
at video and image imagery and Associate
you know intent with that those will all
help in the communication between robots
and and people for sure and that's going
to happen obviously more quickly than
any of us were expecting I mean what
else do you want from life
and then just talk about this the
state of the world
I mean there's a deep loneliness within
all of us and I think
a beer and a good chat solves so much of
it or it takes us a long way to solving
uh it'll be interesting to see
um
you know when
when a generative AI can give you that
warm feeling that you connected
you know and that oh yeah you remember
me you're my friend you know we have a
history
you know that history matters right
memory of joint like memory of yeah
having witnessed I mean that's what
friendship that's what connection that's
what love is in in many cases some of
the deepest friendships you have is
having gone through a difficult time
together and having a shared memory of
an amazing time or a difficult time
and kind of that memory creating this
like Foundation based on which you can
then experience the world together the
silly the mundane stuff of day-to-day is
somehow built on a foundation of having
gone through some in the past and
the the current systems are not
personalized in that way but I think
that's a technical problem not as some
kind of fundamental limitation so I'll
combine that with an embodied robot like
spot which already has magic in its
movement I think uh it's a very
interesting possibility of what where
that takes us but of course you have to
build that on top of a company that's
making money
with real application with real
customers and with robots that are safe
and work and reliable and
manufactured scale
and I think we're in a unique position
in that uh because of you know our
investors primarily Hyundai but also
SoftBank still owns 20 of us
um they don't they're not totally
fixated on
driving us to profitability as soon as
possible that's not the goal the goal
really is a longer term vision of
creating
you know what does mobility mean in the
future what how is this mobile robot
technology going to influence
um us can we and can we shape that and
they want both and so I we are as a
company are trying to strike that
balance between let's build a business
that makes money
I've been describing that to my own team
as
self-destination if I want to if I want
to drive my own ship we need to have a
business that's profitable in the end
otherwise somebody else is going to
drive the ship for us
so that's really important
but we're going to retain
the aspiration that we're going to build
the next generation of Technology at the
same time and the real trick will be if
we can do both